For this problem x equals positive 12. Great effort for getting this one
correct. I hope you're on a roll with these. We start solving by isolating this
cube root on one side of the equal sign. This means we'll have to subtract 5
from both sides, in order to isolate this cubed root. To undo this cube root,
we raise both sides to the third power. The cube of the cube root x minus 4, is
just x minus 4 and the cube of 2 equals 8. Now we're ready to solve for x and
we just add 4 to both sides to get x equals 12 and as always, we want to make
sure to check. We take the value of 12 and plug it in for x into the original
equation. This cube root simplifies to the cube root of 8, which equals
positive 2. 2 plus 5 equals 7. So yes, our solution checks.